hey everyone what's going on some big
news happening in the MCU man I haven't
been this sided about the MCU I think
since Avengers end game and of course
Infinity War now I know there's been
other movies out there that have been
great Shang Chi et cetera et cetera but
there's some really awesome stuff
happening right now of course Spider-Man
no way home and Hawkeye which is
actually turning out to be a pretty damn
good series now there is going to be
spoilers in this video so if you have
not seen Hawkeye episode 5 if you have
not seen Spiderman no way home and you
do not want to be spoiled don't watch
this video right now but if you don't
mind being spoiled and you've seen both
of these uh the show and the movie
let's get into it all right here we go
three two one Wilson Fisk is in Hawkeye
Vincent nonofio from the Netflix series
as we saw with Matt Murdoch Charlie Cox
in Spider-Man no way home is now in the
MCU this is big news I am super pumped
I've been a daredevil fan since I was a
kid I collected the comics I was a huge
fan of the Netflix series Ben Affleck
movie and it was okay but the Netflix
series knocked it out of the park for me
I mean Vincent d'onofrio's Kingpin was
awesome awesome Charlie Cox awesome I
mean you can't get better than these two
guys you really can the fact that
they're in the MCU opens up so many
doors and it also asks a lot of
questions too
how are they going to be in the MCU are
is there going to be anything from the
Netflix series that carries into it are
we going to see characters like Luke
Cage or Jessica Jones or even the
Punisher come in from the Netflix series
into the MCU Granite Iron Fist maybe
maybe not I think that's that ship has
sailed but there's a lot of possibility
for the other characters
so let's talk about it now as we know we
just saw a snapshot of Kingpin next to
Eleanor Bishop okay in the end of
episode five of uh Hawkeye
do you think we're gonna see him more in
episode six I think we are I think there
is going to be some dialogue happening
but will we also see Daredevil or Matt
Murdock
that's a question that would be pretty
damn interesting because the way they
ended episode 5 on Hawkeye I mean
I know with Echo I'm not too sure where
they're gonna go with that character to
be honest with you I think after Ronan
kind of had his way with her I really
don't see how they're going to grow that
series on its own we'll see how that
happens right remains to be seen but it
really sets up obviously a clash between
Elena and Clint Barton you know I'm
liking the fact that they're focusing
more on Clint Barton than they are on
Kate Bishop she's still at the integral
part but I like that they're really
focusing on the OG Hawkeye but are we
going to see Kingpin come out of is it
going to be a Kingpin versus Clint
Barton are we going to see Daredevil get
into the mix there's a lot of
speculation going on I would love to
hear from you guys what you think on
that I mean there is a lot to resolve in
one episode coming up you've got to
resolve Yelena issue you've got Kingpin
in the mix now you still got Echo who's
lingering around
um the Ronin situation this is a lot for
Clint Barton to unpack and resolve
within one episode and also Kate Bishop
as much as I like the character and
she's kind of grown on me I don't think
he's ready for prime time not just yet
so my guess is we're going to see a
season two of Hawkeye announced and
here's my theory this is going to be
part of the larger Defenders uh scenario
now we saw the Defenders thing in
Netflix of course Jessica Jones Luke
Cage Iron Fist Daredevil
but
could we see a new Defender sort of
group Happening Here with
the you know the inclusion of Hawkeye
could it be Kate bishop or could it be
Clint Barton who knows but that would be
very very exciting all right guys before
we go any further here's a quick message
from our sponsor secret lab this video
is brought to you by secret lab here at
geek culture we love our secret lab
chairs especially the all-new 2022 Titan
Evo with its revamped four-way lumbar
system for enhanced back support
leather 2.0 is in your cup of tea then
consider the all new soft weave even
more soft and breathable than before the
chair comes in more colors including
this lovely Frost Bloom the Titan Evo is
even magnetized allowing the head pillow
to stick on the headrest without straps
of course there are even more new
features so do check them out at
secretlab.co
we gotta talk about Matt Murdock being
in Spider-Man no way home I mean I
talked about a little bit about it in my
spoiler review if you haven't seen that
do check that out if you're into
spoilers okay but that scene when that
brick came through the window and he
caught it with his hand not even looking
and you know Peter Parker was like how
did you do that and he's like well I'm a
very good lawyer I love it love the line
love the delivery it was awesome I was I
mean we're watching the movie in
Singapore right and I think some of the
Singapore audience saw Daredevil some
didn't so we weren't getting that like
crazed cheer that you probably get in
America in other countries but man I was
pumped for that and I just love Charlie
Cox's delivery with Matt Murdoch's he's
just awesome in the roles so I mean
Daredevil and Spider-Man have worked
together for a long time it was in the
comics and I would love to see this and
the MCU
um I mean they're setting it up man they
are setting it up of course now he
doesn't know that he's Peter Parker or
does he I don't think he does but this
is going to be very interesting what
happened to this but are we going to see
Daredevil in Hawkeye and then what
happens to like other characters in the
MCU let's say mahershala Ali who's now
blade he was caught mouth on Luke Cage
now we know Kevin foggy will re you know
reuse actors when and if needed he likes
them case in point Gemma Chan Minerva
and Captain Marvel Cersei and uh Eternal
so he will reuse actors when he wants to
and obviously he's doing that mahershal
Ali or will there be a Twist to it this
is gonna be a very interesting uh way of
looking at the Marvel Cinematic Universe
now especially with this this
integration with the Netflix universe so
to speak um I'm super pumped for it and
I would love to hear from you guys what
do you think I have no information
whatsoever we may see Daredevil in
episode six of Hawkeye I just think he
may show up even if it's just him in the
background or baton flying and you just
see him briefly I don't know I don't
know man it would just be awesome if it
happens but I think we may see him in
that
um as for Spider-Man know at home was an
awesome scene I wish they used him more
now granted they had enough heroes in
that movie I don't think they could have
added another one but I cannot wait to
see what they do with these two guys and
these two actors and these characters I
just can't wait for it let's talk about
it let me know in the comment section
below what are your thoughts on this
what do you think is going to happen in
episode six of Hawkeye where do you see
Matt Murdock going from here what would
you like to see between him and Peter
Parker let me know in the comment
section below like always follow us on
Facebook subscribe to our channel right
here like our video helps us out a lot
thank you for the support thus far and
we will chat to you soon take care
[Music]
foreign